paul biya retraite régulièrement des
tensions mais avec le confinement le
manque de sport et le stress les ont
renforcés pour la réouverture de son
cabinet cet ostéopathe versailles et a
dû revoir son organisation au niveau du
cabinet j'ai rallongé mais créneau donc
je prends le patient maintenant 1h15 au
lieu des 45 minutes une heure habituelle
ce qui me permet de pouvoir
aérer le cabinet au moins pendant 15
minutes de pouvoir également désinfecter
les poignées désinfecter la table
désinfectez tout le mobilier ou le
patient va venir s'installer à
l'obligation de porter un masque il ya
du gel
à l'arrivée et dans le kabyle dans la
salles d'attentes
on est tout seul dans la salle d'attenté
la base est propre et non à aider voilà
repourvoir on va faire une petite c2
mois qu'il n'avait pas fait ses gestes
comme de nombreux praticiens paul biard
a dû fermer son cabinet du jour au
lendemain à l annonce du confinement un
temps long pour certains patients ça a
commencé à tirer en bas du dos donc je
me suis dit voilà il fallait que ça
reprenne parce que du coup je voulais
refaire une séance avec mon ostéopathe
est sur que derrière je n'ai pas de
souci et dès que j'ai eus su qui
reprenait les rendez vous j'ai pris un
j'ai pris contact avec lui cet
ostéopathe a pu bénéficier dette de
l'état un moyen pour lui de couvrir les
charges du cabinet et d'éliminer là
aussi quelques tensions